so big data is here it's like actually
impacting a lot of businesses people are
doing all kinds of auto magical stuff on
Netflix or Pandora to tell you what you
like and if you could take another data
set and correlate it to the million
people that you have or so like say a
blood test or I'm not sure wide or
everybody wears a wearable for a hundred
days and you had a complete data set of
a hundred days and I don't know blood
test
what would you be able to tell us or
what would the research be able to tell
us and has anybody done anything
remotely close to matching those kind of
data sets the activity that yeah thank
you yeah but he said yeah it's and we we
debate this quite quite a bit in part
because also there's so much data that's
coming in and what's the right data and
sometimes you kind of want all of it you
know blood data I would say to start
with blood data is probably the most
valuable because you want to potentially
be able to correlate trends in your in
your standard lab values with
potentially an early diagnosis for
something you know the activity data you
don't necessarily need all of the data
that is coming but you put as she needs
certain kinds of data points or the
deltas the changes that are happening
there's all kinds of things that are
gonna be interesting that people don't
realize so for instance we had a talk
yesterday in the office about
Parkinson's disease and people who have
REM sleep disorders or like who have
problems sleeping it's it's a predictor
for Parkinson's in certainly uniform
like these people end up having a
problem and apparently the sleep doctors
always knew this but it never translated
over to the neurologists and and there's
things like that in people with
Parkinson's as well they start to lose
their sense of smell so there's things
that are gonna be really interesting to
be able to detect what I think about
always from our research angle is what
is it that the consumers want and
ideally like we're all in the room
everyone's relatively young in here you
want to know how to prevent disease and
so there's two things to me that are
interesting and prevention is one is the
things that you do day in and day out as
you eat and you breathe your environment
and so I'm super interested in what is
it that you're eating and how does it
actually potentially really influence
and any kind of environmental exposures
so like Environmental Working Group does
a bunch of interesting studies I'm like
like what truly is the harm of Teflon in
your food and you know like I would love
to do that I did a body burden study
eight years ago where I was really high
in fire at fire retardants and it was a
thing fire returned fire retardant and
they joked they're like oh you must fly
a lot in coach and I said yes because I
was from the wall street is like you fly
all the time like that's if you think
about airplanes are covered in fire
retardants and your breathing circulated
air so you're absorbing a lot of fire
retardants and so I think that there's
it's just kind of interesting to study
those components because what the
consumer ultimately is gonna want is
like you want to stay healthy and if I
can give you that guide for staying
healthy so it's a little bit of a long
answer I mean I do think that the blood
data and in medical records are gonna be
sort of first priority list for us but
then figuring out a way that you can
really track environment and you know
GPS from your phones that matches with
pollution statistics from the country
and sort of your gross you know how much
are you actually exercising every day on
a relative basis to appears like that
information is going to be super
valuable